Matthew I want to talk frankly with this
other life you let it's your heart still
with it what is your heart will the one
who walked through it by your side
Elektra yeah I do miss her but I know
that the things she brought out of me
were wrong from what you've told me
about her I think she'd be happy about
how well you're doing maybe well maybe
she told me I'm abandoning that life and
with it her memory they're not a band
that he left her you don't have it in
you what you're doing
we call that moving on Purgatory's a
place for the dead Matthew not the
living it's nothing wrong with letting
people go she'll find her peace I pray
you find yours as well
Oh
hey youtubers brand new defenders let's
break it down and a quick reminder all
the episodes are dropping in almost like
two weeks it's on the 18th so I'll be
doing videos for all that be sure to
subscribe to get everything
let me a special Marvel giveaway we'll
do a bunch of fun stuff but there's a
couple big things going on in this clip
so if you haven't watched daredevil
season 2 in a while they're picking up
where they left off with Elektra he's in
confessional with father'll anthem and
he hasn't been daredevil for almost a
year now so ever since that last moment
in daredevil season 2 where he confessed
his identity to Karen Paige
I'm daredevil he hasn't been wearing the
costume defenders picks up about six
months after iron fist you have to
assume that they happen in relatively
linear fashion so the events of iron
fist are happening after the events of
daredevil season 2 so it'll have been
almost a year and a half so we have to
talk about what's been happening since
then in the daredevil universe because
we've seen the other shows like we saw
what happened during Luke Cage we saw
what happened during Jessica Jones most
of us saw what happened during iron fist
they say that that series was the most
watched Netflix series so far Netflix
doesn't report ratings the way that
normal TV shows do so it's hard to tell
how popular each of the different
defenders series are compared to the
others but their other big topic of
discussion is Elektra the corpse that we
still think is in the ground Matt
doesn't know anything about her coming
back from the dead the hands stealing
her resurrecting her in her being
co-opted by Alexandra as we saw during
the defenders trailer I did have a
chance to see episode 1 but I'm going to
wait to post my non-spoilery review
video till it gets ready to drop but
without giving away spoilers they pick
up with each of the different characters
and let you know what they've been doing
since we last saw them so it's been the
longest for daredevil so he just been
working as a normal attorney as Matt
Murdock this whole time there's been no
daredevil he just been Matt Murdock
trying to live the normal life so
obviously that's not going to work out
like when he considers maybe she'll feel
like I abandoned this thing that I was
supposed to be doing if she were in the
right frame of mind which she is not
which I'll explain in a second she would
be pissed that he's not daredevil that
was the most fun thing ever for her she
was a double agent for stick trying to
get Matt to join this war she was
trying to get him to leave all of this
Matt Murdock stuff behind so all this is
the opposite of what she would want
the actress Elodie Young has explained
that after her resurrection she has a
form of amnesia so she has no idea
what's going on
she doesn't remember her time with Matt
she doesn't remember what she was doing
with stick so she's this assassins raw
lump of clay that Alexandra is trying to
fashion into her own version of The
Punisher I would say her own version of
iron Fitz but that's kind of a separate
thing if you remember iron fist Season
one they said that there's somebody that
we know that would really like to meet
you that's probably Alexandra like they
want to use them as their own personal
boogeyman so now they have a version of
that in Elektra they haven't said a
whole lot about it but you have to
remember that she is another black sky
so it's been a while since we've touched
on that but essentially what I think
they're doing is they're using that is a
version of the beast from the comics
which is the thing that the hand
worships and allows them to resurrect
people so the TV show might take a
slightly different spin on it but it's
basically more of a possession situation
where she becomes the embodiment of this
terrible evil thing the way that iron
fist harnesses Chi as well as wielding
the power of Shu loud the dragon he's
supposed to be the mortal enemy of the
hand so if black sky is sort of the
reverse version of iron fist that'd be
pretty cool but in the comics
technically that's still serpent so we
could just think of her as black sky
right now but it's not like she's going
to be shooting energy beams from her
eyes or anything like that so she just
spends the entire trailer in that
voiceover the Sigourney Weaver voiceover
trying to tell her that everybody's
going to let her down those aren't her
friends so she might remember them just
a little bit I think they want to leave
the window open so that you understand
that it's possible for her to go back to
Matt but it's probably going to take
most of the episodes half of the action
of the trailer is Elektra kicking all
their asses so it'll be fun to see how
that plays out because even though
Elektra was kind of weird during
daredevil season two I felt like on a
character level she was way more
interesting than say someone like Karen
page even though all that Karen page
stuff with him was kind of cute it's not
that kind of show if this were a network
show it would be more like the SNL
version of Black Widow where they get
married at the end they have a child and
they move off to the suburbs this is not
a parody of a Marv
old stories so that's why the Elektra
step is so much more fun and just on a
comic book level she's a lot more
interesting I suppose I'll never have to
have again I could always tell people
you gotta play acoustic y'all won't
believe you anyway so really this clip
is just for the daredevil stuff where
they pick up with him they'll have a
version of this with Luke Cage Jessica
Jones an iron fist they'll probably drop
those promos in the next couple of weeks
it's creeping up a lot closer than you
think so what will happen is when we get
closer I'll post that non-spoilery
review video and then depending on
interest level all two videos for every
episode or every one or two episodes
there's only eight so hopefully I'll
have all that stuff out within the first
week of it airing but there will be a
lot of people that binge it all at once
but I think most people kind of take the
whole week to get through it but it'll
be really cool will have defenders and
Game of Thrones on and Rick and Morty at
the same time so there's actually a lot
of awesome TV happening this summer but
I know you're all asking about that
Punisher footage they drop the Comic Con
I've already done a breakdown of it I
did that during my defenders trailer
video so I'll link that at the end of
this but what they'll probably do is
they'll release that at the end of
defenders in just a reminder the
defenders has a legit Marvel style
post-credit scene in that at the end of
episode 8 it's not after every single
episode they haven't said yet whether or
not there'll be a second season their
defenders but I think it's a foregone
conclusion I think they just want to see
how everybody reacts to season what a
defenders because they know how well
each of the individual series do but
defenders is a whole different beast
well what will happen is is there's a
couple more comic-con trailers to get
through I have Walking Dead Season eight
so I'll do a video for that next I
should be up in a couple hours there's
some Young Justice I want to post
tomorrow and some new Game of Thrones
maybe some ant-man in the wasps this
weekend too they released a production
teaser and there's a little bit of stuff
we know about the movie so while you
wait for everything click here to
rewatch that defenders trailer and you
can click here for my infinity war
trailer from comic-con thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight